this is Nautica the oil tanker that will
replace the FSL Surfer the decaying
vessel is threatening to spill more than
a million barrels of oil into the Red
Sea it's a big day for healthy officials
they are joining the signing ceremony of
an agreement that allows Yemen's Safa
company to own and run the new tanker
we reached a deal to prevent a disaster
that would affect the entire region
affect fishermen with millions of
dollars we are preventing a potential
catastrophe that would have cost
billions
this is the man who played a crucial
role in galvanizing International
opinion against the threats of a major
oil spill
David Grassley is the resident and
humanitarian coordinator for the United
Nations
the global fundraising he launched
generated more than a hundred million
dollars needed to salvage the suffer
mode off the coast of hadida and by this
new vessel that took a long time to
convince everybody a government's
private sector that this was actually
viable and I can understand why why
people would be skeptical given the
multiple attempts to deal with it in the
past that did not succeed
um and and the fact that it was still
very active as a as a as a civil war but
the Safa isn't just an environmental
threat since the start of the war 80
years ago it has become a divisive
political issue the internationally
recognized government of Yemen based in
adensae they are the ones who should own
the Safar and the Nautica and that the
revenues from the sale of the oil stuck
on the software should be transferred to
its accounts the houthis control hodada
Sana and the North and say they are the
legitimate Authority in Yemen
85 of the population in Yemen lives in
the areas controlled by the government
of Sana we have shown they are able to
stand for the rights and interest of the
yemenis we will preserve Yemen's assets
the Nautica will be more next to suffer
so the oil can be transferred
the risk of a major oil spill may be
diminishing but the site remains tightly
guarded technical support teams are
operating non-stop any damage to the old
and poorly maintained Safa could
discharge escargot of oil and devastate
marine ecosystems in the Red Sea Gulf of
Aden and Suez Canal the arrival of the
Nautica Yemen is a milestone it took
months of negotiations with all the
warring Fashions as well as the
International Community to get to this
point the UN hopes this will lead to the
start of talks to end the conflict and
heal the political divide
off the coast of hodeidah Yemen